Trascrizione: Florencia Fragapane
Revisore: Barbara Dalla Villa
Vi è mai capitato
di scontrarvi frontalmente
contro un ciclista o un'altra bicicletta?
E nel caso, che cosa avete fatto?
A: siete caduti, avete rimbalzato,
e siete volati via come un supereroe.
B: avete smesso di andare
in bicicletta per sempre.
C: avete creato un'app digitale,
come ho fatto io.
Bene, ma adesso ve la spiego,
solo che devo andare
un po' indietro nel tempo,
a quando ero bambino.
Perché io sono stato
un bambino, come tutti voi.
Io ero un bambino biondo
con gli occhi azzurri.
In quel tempo dicevano
che assomigliavo a Shirley Temple,
per chi se la ricorda,
ma vi assicuro che era un paragone
che non mi andava molto a genio.
C'era un concorso:
bisognava inviare la propria fotografia,
del proprio bambino,
con questa scatola di biscotti in mano.
Il concorso era bandito da questa marca,
e io, che mi sentivo già
di diventare qualcuno,
forse un attore famoso,
ogni volta in cui la macchina
fotografica era davanti a me,
mi spostavo, cercavo
la luce e la posa migliore.
Forse perché cercavo già
di diventare importante, cercavo la luce.
Ma sapete come andò a finire?
Quella foto venne stampata, ma mia mamma
non la mandò mai per il concorso,
e i miei sogni di gloria svanirono.
Ma questa è un'altra storia.
Crescevo, e i miei sogni iniziavano
a prendere forme e dimensioni diverse,
con colori più vivi,
coi toni più accesi, più reali.
Sognavo, come tutti voi da bambini,
di diventare un supereroe.
Allora prendevo
il maglione rosso di mia mamma,
me lo legavo sulle spalle
e diventavo Superman.
Poi prendevo quei sacchi
della spazzatura neri -
sapete, quelli grandi -
me li mettevo sulle spalle
e diventavo Batman.
Il sacco era pulito ovviamente.
Sogni e ancora sogni.
Poi a cinque anni arrivò lei,
la mia prima biciclettina.
Me la ricordo come se fosse qua
in questo momento:
rossa, piccolina, con le rotelle.
E voi non ci crederete,
ma io con questa bicicletta
ho vinto tre Giri d'Italia,
due Tour de France
e una serie infinita
di tappe a cronometro in montagna.
E anche un Campionato del Mondo.
Sempre da solo, e sempre all'interno
del mio piccolo cortile di casa.
Mi sbucciavo le ginocchia,
battevo il naso,
ma la mia creatività,
il mio sognare ad occhi aperti,
mi spingeva ad esplorare nuove mappe,
a cercare nuovi territori.
Cresco, e ad un certo punto,
in altri contesti come quello lavorativo,
inizio a lavorare in una multinazionale.
Wow.
Il posto fisso, i primi soldini.
Mi compro una bella macchina, e porto
qualche bella ragazza fuori a cena.
Però il posto fisso,
l'effetto wow, mi dura poco.
Sapete perché?
In quel periodo continuavo ad esercitare
quella che viene considerata
tra le attività più comuni
e intime di noi esseri umani:
sognare.
Perché sognare ad occhi aperti
ci porta a raggiungere i nostri obiettivi.
Perché i sogni sono fatti
di paure, di incertezze
e di limiti che vanno individuati,
cercati, trovati, superati.
D'altronde, lo diceva anche Aristotele
che la speranza è sognare ad occhi aperti;
e allora forte di questo motto,
un bel giorno scrivo
quella che sarebbe diventata forse
la mia lettera più importante.
Ma non una lettera d'amore.
Scrissi una lettera lunga.
Avevo un sorriso a 36 denti,
camminavo a mezzo metro da terra
e ricordo ancora l'odore
di quella moquette verde
di quel corridoio che avrei percorso
per l'ultima volta.
Andavo dal capo
del personale, a licenziarmi.
E con me portai un'altra lettera
di licenziamento, scritta sempre da me.
Ma per un mio collega,
che sarebbe diventato
il mio primo socio in affari,
a sua insaputa;
lo feci dimettere io,
sempre a sua insaputa.
E così, a 25 anni
mi ritrovo a fare l'imprenditore.
Che bello.
Non sapevo neanche cosa volesse dire.
Ma avevo una bella macchina,
avevo un telefono,
un computer aperto sulle gambe,
e tanta voglia di fare
e di sognare ancora.
In quel tempo mi rendo conto
di come la mia mente funzioni
generando una serie infinita
di immagini, una dopo l'altra,
che vengono messe
in un perfetto piano sequenza,
immaginate un cortometraggio TV,
che rappresentavano,
e rappresentano ancora oggi,
quelli che io chiamo i miei sogni.
Allora comprendo che questa, forse,
è la strategia necessaria
per esprimermi nel mondo.
Ma non mi piace chiamarla così,
mi piace definirla "Il gioco del bambino
con la scatola di biscotti"
che è dentro di me.
Gioca e sogna, e me ne rendo conto
mentre cresco mente divento grande,
l'involucro cresce,
ma il bambino è dentro di me,
e le mie idee, le mie ipotesi,
le situazioni che io immagino
nella mia testa, nella mia creatività,
si trasformano pian piano
in azioni reali, concrete
perché si introiettano nei miei muscoli.
Il bambino continua a essere dentro di me
e gioca uno schema di gioco dopo l'altro.
Ecco qual è l'approccio
che io ho alla vita:
è un approccio ludico.
Io vivo la vita con leggerezza:
ma non la banalizzo, perché ho
la consapevolezza di un adulto.
Non faccio il buffone, ma vivo giocando.
Questo mi dà energia, mi dà forza,
mi fa stare bene con me stesso.
Tutto vero.
Ma a un certo punto, la vita mi riserva
un forte, doloroso shock.
Immaginate un pugno dritto,
qua, nello stomaco,
di quelli che fanno maledettamente male,
dal quale farete fatica a riprendervi
e non lo scorderete mai.
Il bambino con la scatola
di biscotti diventa grande:
diventa prima imprenditore, poi si sposa,
ha un bambino -
il mio primogenito Leonardo -
e poi nasce la mia secondogenita Noemi,
che per un problema di salute
ritorna in ospedale dopo qualche giorno.
E ricordo ancora quella giornata.
La bimba con pochi giorni,
febbre altissima.
Mia moglie la porta al pronto soccorso.
Io rimango a casa da solo
col bimbo grande, che aveva tre anni.
Vado a dormire nel lettone,
e lui, che percepisce qualcosa che non va,
viene nel letto con me
e ci addormentiamo abbracciati.
Dopo qualche ora
si accende la luce della camera,
e sulla porta mia moglie, che mi dice:
"Hanno ricoverato d'urgenza Noemi.
L'hanno portata in terapia intensiva,
e non possiamo neanche vederla".
Di quel momento ricordo un buio fortissimo
che non è il ricordo di un'immagine,
ma il ricordo di un dolore.
Ricordo il volto scavato dalle lacrime
di mia moglie.
E inizio a vivere un momento
di solitudine interiore,
che si trasforma presto in paura.
Game over.
Tutto quello che vi ho detto fino adesso,
la scatola di biscotti, i sogni,
il giocare, l'ottimismo,
gli entusiasmi, successi, wow.
Non c'è più niente.
La scatola di biscotti non si apre più.
Finito.
Stop.
Game over.
Per fortuna però Noemi, dopo un periodo
che non ricordo neanche più quanto,
perché l'ho vissuto in apnea,
si ristabilisce e torna a casa.
E oggi, viva Dio,
è una bambina che sta bene.
Però io sono ancora
in quella fase di standby.
Siamo nel 2016.
Per sbaglio, su Internet,
trovo un libro con questo titolo
"Volevo solo pedalare".
Sarà l'assonanza che ha
con la mia passione, la bicicletta,
e allora lo compro.
È un libro di Alex Zanardi.
Inizio a leggerlo.
Dopo qualche pagina mette in me
già una voglia di ripartire
e di rinascere incredibile,
una carica pazzesca.
Perché l'autore, Zanardi, racconta
come il suo bruttissimo incidente
lo abbia ovviamente cambiato,
ma l'abbia fatto rinascere.
Perché lui sì, ha perso
metà del suo corpo, le gambe,
ma è rimasta la parte importante,
quella con la testa e quella con il cuore.
E allora anche io decido di ripartire
con la testa e con il cuore.
Voglio fare qualcosa,
rispolverando il mio vecchio sogno,
qualcosa per i turisti che come me
vanno su e giù nelle vigne
e nei boschi con la bicicletta,
ma non so ancora che cosa.
Voglio fare qualcosa
per quelli che, nel territorio,
cercano informazioni ma non le trovano.
E sono ancora in standby,
la scatola di biscotti non si riapre.
Finché una mattina,
siamo ad ottobre avanzato del 2018,
a un certo punto mi infilo la tutina
per andare in bicicletta.
Fa freddo, e c'è la nebbia.
La famiglia mi guarda
come un pazzo si guarda
appena uscito dal manicomio.
Veramente: la tutina, fa freddo,
uscire in bicicletta
alle otto con cinque gradi,
credo non invogliava nessuno.
Eppure parto.
Faccio un percorso in discesa.
Dall'altra parte, sale un pazzo come me
e SBAM! Un colpo incredibile.
Un altro pazzo come me che viene su.
È un ciclista, ovviamente, norvegese.
Quei norvegesi alti coi capelli biondi,
faccia rossa e con lo sguardo freddo,
che mi guarda e inizia a parlarmi
con un suo inglese che non comprendo.
Io gli rispondo in piemontese.
Non ci capiamo.
Ma una cosa me la fa intuire,
mi dice che al fondo del sentiero
c'è il suo camper, di andare da lui.
Mi avrebbe dato del ghiaccio
da mettere sul gomito,
che io nel frattempo non muovevo più.
Lo ascolto.
Saliamo su quel camper
e vedo la sua fiancata.
Un simbolo di uno smartphone
e di una bicicletta.
Mentre lui mi sta medicando gli chiedo:
"Ma Bjorn" - che ormai
eravamo migliori amici -
"ma che lavoro fai? "
E lui mi spiega
che porta dei turisti norvegesi
in Langa, con la bicicletta.
Solo che deve venire prima in Italia,
a tracciare i percorsi,
a cercare le cose caratteristiche,
per poi rivendere questo pacchetto.
Gli dico: "Bjorn, questa cosa
mi fa venire in mente
un'altra cosa, un mio desiderio. "
E allora la mia mente inizia di nuovo
a produrre quelle immagini.
Inizio a vedere migliaia di turisti
con lo smartphone in mano,
che finalmente riescono ad orientarsi
con una sola app, in qualsiasi posto,
dove si trovano, in Italia e nel mondo.
Allora lo guardo negli occhi e gli dico:
"Bjorn, quello di cui tu hai bisogno,
di cui han bisogno milioni di turisti,
è semplicemente un'app. E te la farò io."
Bingo.
Di lì parte un nuovo schema di gioco:
il mio nuovo gioco,
quello che sto vivendo oggi.
Ovvero aver creato un'app digitale,
col mio team di sviluppo,
tra le più scaricate e utilizzate
in Italia a pochi mesi dal lancio.
Un'app che vi permette
di scoprire il territorio
attraverso la realtà aumentata.
Ve la faccio più semplice.
Immaginate il cane da tartufo
che accompagna il trifolau
sul territorio.
Alla scoperta del tartufo stesso.
Ecco, immaginate un cagnolino
con il naso estremamente sviluppato
che percepisce cose
che voi non riuscite a percepire.
Vi accompagna.
Quindi torri, castelli,
sentieri e quant'altro.
Questo è il successo di oggi,
che sto vivendo con il mio
nuovo schema di gioco
e col mio nuovo sognare ad occhi aperti.
E quindi, come il bambino
con la scatola di biscotti
che in questo momento è dentro di me,
ed è orgoglioso di aver creato
una nuova scatola,
ma questa volta digitale,
io auguro a tutti voi
di trovare o di ritrovare
quel bambino con la scatola di biscotti
che è dentro ognuno di voi.
E che ci aiuti, e vi aiuti,
a vivere la vita con leggerezza,
con la vostra consapevolezza da adulto,
a tratti con follia
e che vi permetta
di raggiungere i vostri sogni.
Grazie.
(Applausi)